sam darnold no longer seeing ghosts
shireen he's seeing panthers as of today
the jets quarterback the third overall
pick in the 2018 draft traded
out of the blue the carolina blue
to the panthers four
20 21 sixth round pick 2022 second round
pick 2022 fourth round pick thank you
to the jets and the panthers for picking
a day a monday could have done it
yesterday could have done it the day
before thank you for waiting until
monday so we can milk that cow properly
shireen good afternoon how are you
well it was a slow news day mike but all
of a sudden it picked up right about an
hour ago and so here we are got big news
on the horizon this is fun this is a fun
offseason i hate when people ask me what
are you doing the offseason this is what
we do in the off season mike
yeah hey what do you do once football
season ends you just lay around sure i
lay around we're busier from the end of
football season until training camp for
the most part than we are during
football season and this offseason with
the quarterback carousel sims and i were
talking earlier today in the context of
a jimmy garoppolo trade that the spots
are shrinking
and with the panthers drafting eighth
and the broncos drafting ninth in both
teams
obviously interested in upgrading at the
quarterback position
there wasn't much more that could really
happen
and i thought the jets would hold on to
sam darden until after round one played
out and then have an auction for darnold
between the end of round one and the
start of round two roughly 18 hours
earlier like the cardinals did two years
ago when they acquired kyle murray with
the first overall pick traded josh rose
in the 10th overall pick from the same
year darnold was drafted but the
panthers my guess is after swinging and
missing on matthew stafford and whoever
else they were trying to get whatever
else they were trying to do i think mike
tannebaum the former jets gm and former
dolphins executive has suggested that
the panthers were one of the ones trying
to move up to get in position to draft
mac jones
you get to a point where you've just had
enough let's just call the ball let's
get it done let's know what we're going
to have what they're going to have is
sam darnold shereen
and you know i think the impetus for all
this mike was the 49ers trade up last
week that kind of took the 49ers out of
play for sam darnold which you know
there have been speculation that that's
probably where he was going to end up
well it became obvious that wasn't going
to happen once that trade happened and
it became obvious that the panthers
weren't going to get up into that top
three more than likely to draft their
quarterbacks so they really were out of
options at this point and i think
frankly mike the jets were out of
options at this point because the 49ers
were no longer in that trade talk and
perhaps the panthers said hey this is
our last best offer take it or leave it
and at that point maybe the jets said
all right let's let's move on from
saying arnold we don't care that we're
playing our hand we have the second pick
overall anyway we're gonna get zach
wilson if we don't get trevor lawrence
he's our guy we don't care that
everybody knows he's our guy so i think
it worked out for both sides at this
point you know what i think it's a win
for the panthers because if he doesn't
work out
they are going to have a high pick next
year and they'll be back in that
quarterback derby the one thing that
worries me about the the panthers
commitment to sam darnold is they are
picking up that fifth year option mic
which is 18 million dollars so they'll
be locked into that
but i'm not so certain that this is
their quarterback the future but they
get to find out and if and if he is and
he works out great
they've got their guy and they've got
him for relatively inexpensive if he's
not their guy they'll be back here next
year or perhaps at the trade deadline to
go get deshaun watson
here's the reality this is the first
year that picking up the fifth year
option makes it fully guaranteed from
the moment it's exercise so that 18
million for 2022 that's part of what
they are stepping into now the good news
is he only will cost 920 000 this year
in salary along with
where is it 3.8 million dollars in a
pre-season roster bonus so total salary
about 4.8 for sam darnold this year
that's a bargain next year is when it
becomes more expensive
18.858 million nearly 19 million dollars
fully guaranteed as of next year so
they they clearly believe in them and
they wouldn't have done it now we got to
rewind to
2018
six weeks before the draft it was a
saturday colts and jets that time around
didn't wait for monday so screw them
three years later they did the trade
early saturday morning nine ten o'clock
the jets and colts flip flop three and
six and the jets in addition to giving
up their six overall pick they got the
third pick but gave up three second
round picks to go up three spots now
this time around when they unload sam
darnold they get that sixth round pick
this year second round pick next year
fourth round pick next year i thought
that what they would get for sam darnold
would essentially be
a 2021 second round pick someone who is
looking for a quarterback has a second
round pick do the deal maybe a little
more on top of it for them to get three
picks now the second round is next year
which makes it less valuable than this
year obviously but i think they did a
little bit better than i thought they
would for darnold given that
there was hardly a land rush for
a guy who once upon a time was regarded
as the top pick in 2018. i mean in the
2017 season darnold was the guy but that
shine is long gone from sand arnold
sherina
yeah absolutely mike and i thought they
gave up too much perhaps if they're
thinking about getting into that desean
watson derby whenever that happens and
and i think we all expect that to be at
some point after the draft whether it's
at the trade deadline before the season
or sometime next off season but at some
point the texas are going to have to
move on from deshaun watson so i figured
the panthers if they were going to trade
for a quarterback would give up capital
for this year to hold on to that to be
able to trade for desean watson but that
didn't happen so the jets have moved on
from san darnold mike if you look at
their drafts from 2013 to 2018 their
first rounders they traded every single
one of them richardson pryor williams
lee adams and now darnold but they do
have 21 picks over the next two years no
secret why they why they haven't been
good and they aren't good it's because
they haven't drafted real well they've
traded all those guys they've got to get
better at that joe douglas has
shown a penchant for being good in the
draft he's got 21 now over the next two
years to make it work
yeah and this is all about tearing down
and building up gradually all the picks
that were made by mike mckagne in the
former gm being thrown overboard as joe
douglas puts his imprint on the team and
with
a quarterback
i've said this time and again three
types of teams teams that have franchise
quarterbacks teams that are desperately
looking for one and teams that have a
guy that they're not quite sure whether
or not he's going to be a franchise
quarterback so let's see what happens
for the jets three years that was enough
for them to come to the conclusion that
it's time to move on
and it's hard to fault them for it
because
at some point i don't care who the
surrounding cast is
at some point a guy who is destined to
become one of the five to ten best
quarterbacks in the nfl on a consistent
year and year out basis is going to show
us that in his first three seasons in
the nfl now maybe this is going to be a
bit of a vinnie test of verdi
flamed out with his first team and all
of a sudden figured it out with his
second team and that's not unprecedented
although it doesn't happen often but the
jets are making the calculated decision
here that
they've seen what they're going to get
out of darnold and they're in position
to get someone else i think that's the
other side of this we can't overlook
trading donald means they're definitely
not that we doubted it but they're
definitely going quarterback at number
two and they're ready to hand the keys
to that guy shireen knowing that the
last guy three years enough to know not
working now let's roll the dice again
and if this one doesn't work you'll be
back in position possibly with a new gm
and a new head coach to roll the dice
again
yeah it tells you i think mike how much
they love zach wilson right and and they
think that he's going to be better than
what sam darnold is and i don't fault
him for that if you think the guy you
can draft is better than the guy you
have on the roster you make that move
and i said that repeatedly i said last
year that's what the lion should have
done with that third over overall pick
was take justin herbert they didn't do
it so if you're in position to do that
and you really like a guy you think can
be a franchise quarterback you take him
and you take him when you have that
opportunity you know say well we're
gonna give the guy one more year just to
see what he can do just to see if he can
come into his own you've seen him for
three years you think you know what he
is you think zach wilson is better pull
the trigger make that move and they've
done it so kudos to them if it doesn't
work out you're right mike it's going to
cost the gm and the coach their jobs
just like it does repeatedly when things
don't work out with quarterbacks who are
drafted high but they they pulled the
trigger on a guy they think is really
really good by moving on from sam
darnold
joe douglas gm of the jets said this i
want to publicly acknowledge the
commitment dedication and
professionalism sam displayed while with
the jets he is a tough-minded talented
football player whose nfl story has not
been written yet while all these things
are true this move is in the short and
long-term best interest of both this
team and him we thank sam for all of his
work on behalf of this organization and
we wish him well as he continues his
career and i would say about 12 to 15 of
that joe douglas actually means but
but look it's it it's possible that it's
the right move for everyone it's a
long-term win-win it's time for a new
start for darnold it's time for a new
start for the jets the jets are in
position to take zach wilson or whoever
they believe is going to be potentially
their next joe namath 50 years later
that's what the jets are looking for
that's what the jets need that's what
the jets want
and sam darnold getting a chance with an
offense that may be better suited to him
with a coaching staff that may be better
suited to him who knows a a running back
in christian mccaffrey that is clearly
better than anyone who's been in the
backfield behind sam darnold receivers
who are better than anything sam
darnold's had to work with he'll be
reunited with robbie anderson also in
carolina so this could work for sam
darnold and he could end up being great
and it's a risk the jets are willing to
take because the bottom line is they had
to ask themselves this shireen
24 million or so 23 million 22 million
over the next two years for darnold if
they picked up the option and then what
did they do versus rolling the dice from
scratch with a new guy and i think it
was a no-brainer because again i believe
you're going to declare yourself within
three years if you're truly a franchise
quarterback he's shown moments just like
that run on a monday night against the
denver broncos unless it was a thursday
night it was a night game one way or the
other but but not enough not consistent
enough not good enough not a franchise
quarterback not a shortlist franchise
quarterback period
i'm going to be curious to see how he
does in carolina mike because as you
pointed out the weapons certainly are
better he had one of the worst rosters
of in the nfl over the last three years
he did not have adequate coaching over
the last three years so he gets a chance
to have all that in carolina if it
doesn't work out there i think we're
going to see the last of sam darnold
he'll he'll end up probably out of the
league doing something else in the next
couple years so this is really his last
best chance to to get it done on the
field maybe he ends up a backup backup
quarterback if it doesn't work out in
carolina but this is his chance to get
it done
chase chase daniel just texted to say
not so fast shereen there's a good
living to be made holding a clipboard
indefinitely in the national football
league as i've said time and again there
aren't enough bad quarterbacks to go
around all due respect to chase daniel
but but to go two or three deep on a
depth chart yeah sam darnold will
continue to be employed if he wants to
be a backup his window of opportunity to
be a starter is about to to close if it
doesn't work out for him with the
carolina panthers and either way the
panthers got two years to figure out
what they're going to do with this guy
long term he's either a guy you're going
to sign to a long-term contract it won't
necessarily be the richest contract in
nfl history and i continue to believe
that as we see this ongoing evolution of
quarterback contracts there's going to
be tears now it's not going to be the
next guy who has just passed the test
and looks the part is going to become
the highest paid quarterback in league
history there's going to be a tier for
those guys who are just kind of okay and
a tier for the true greats but sam
darnold could get that top of tier two
money if everything goes well for him in
carolina
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports